advice on finding your passion from  jennifer lopez as seen in zugu101  my parents wanted me to be a lawyer but  i don't think i would have been very  happy  up in front of the jury singing i was  always a singer and a dancer and i  always wanted to be an actress  for me it's all just one thing i had a  lot of dreams  a lot of things i wanted to do from the  time i was really young  a real little girl and i just went after  that  i knew i wanted to be a dancer i knew i  needed to be a dancer  i maintained faith in myself and what i  wanted to do  if you focus on the money you're not  going to get anywhere  you can want to be successful but at the  end of the day if money is your  motivation  if that's how shallow your outlook is on  life then you're going to be such an  empty person  because there's nothing driving you from  the inside there's no passion  to learn more check out zugo 101 in the  link below